Introvert or extrovert. With social
media, you can be both. Hello world,
it's Siraj and not many developers
realize how important the role of social
media is in their careers.
In this video,
I'll show you how you can use different
social media platforms to help you learn
cutting edge technologies,
network and promote your own brand.
When I was working at Twillio
on the developer education team,
we had to learn the art of
marketing to developers.
Developers are a smart bunch.
Normal marketing methods
don't work on them.
They know bs when they
see it like certain ICO.
So it's best to be upfront,
honest,
and crystal clear about whatever
your message to them is.
That means you can just
spam them with generic ads.
It has to happen organically.
Your message has to be targeted.
You have to be able to relate to them
and what better way to interact with
developers then the social
media platforms they live on.
So let's start with Twitter.
Twitter is my favorite social network.
I use it like an RSS feed.
I followed all the people I really admire
and when I spend my time scrolling on
Twitter,
unlike every other social network,
I'm actually learning
and improving myself.
Whether it's through book recommendations,
Techno Philosophical Tweet,
storms, board, young Macoun,
or staying up to date with the latest
research from the AI or blockchain
industries. I could start listing
a bunch of smart people to follow,
but instead I'll just say go to my
Twitter profile and see the couple hundred
people I'm following. Follow
them one by one. Also,
if you go to lists and see the lists
I'm a member of that other Twitter users
have created,
you'll very fast start seeing people who
are influential in computer science and
you can follow them easily.
You want to be ruthlessly
precise about who you follow.
These are the people you
are letting influence you,
but Twitter's best use case is networking.
I've used Twitter to directly engage
with brands and people I care about.
I've coordinated collaboration's through
Twitter's direct messaging feature.
Many opportunities have emerged.
It's a much more accessible and
faster way to interact. Then email,
so if there's someone you want to reach
out to before sending them an email,
see if they have an
active Twitter profile.
Chances are you'll get
a reply much faster.
I'm also always promoting
my videos on Twitter.
I even start generating hype
for my videos beforehand.
Sometimes weeks in advance,
which results in more views.
You can do the same for any
project you are working on,
whether it's code or a technical content.
The Twitter community is
technical and collaborative,
so if tweet out quality content,
it will be retweeted
endlessly so on to read it.
I've talked a lot about using the
machine learning sub reddit as a primary
resource of mine to stay up to date
with the latest news in artificial
intelligence and it still is.
However,
it's not the only surprise that
that's relevant to this field.
I've compiled a list
of other ones I visit.
Everything I talk about in this video,
we'll be in the video description.
My second favorite is data is beautiful.
There are some really
inspiring visualizations there.
If you're ever feeling
disillusioned with the field,
it's not a great platform for networking,
but it will definitely keep you updated
if you visit often and don't go on too
many sub reddit tangents.
I've also found out the hard way that
reddit is really strict about posting your
content too much without
contributing to discussions,
so if you have something
valuable to share,
make sure to balance it by engaging
with other posts just as much.
Speaking of engagement,
Facebook gets a lot of hate these days
for profiting off of user data and it
should,
but regardless,
it's still a great platform
to find career opportunities.
There are a few Facebook groups I've found
that are full of helpful and creative
technologists in both AI and blockchain.
The great thing about Facebook is that
everyone is using their real identity,
so if you actively engage with
people in a specific Facebook group,
you will become known in that group.
It's a fast track to close
relationships with others in the field.
Also posting code and content in these
groups will give you feedback fast and
you can post it in a bunch of
groups all at once with no limits.
Prepare yourself for a
notification storm though,
but notifications aren't just limited
to Facebook. What's up youtube?
Youtube is a great platform for education,
although it didn't use to be so many
amazing creators have been sharing high
quality free content on here.
When it comes to technical content,
there's of course sent
decks who's indepth?
Python tutorials are very helpful.
Three blue,
one brown who makes some of the best
math animations in the world and you'll
shift men who teaches creative coding
via javascript and a young 10 may box
sheet who is like a younger version of
me and will probably take over the world
one day.
As for nontechnical channels,
definitely check out charisma on command.
I want you guys to be confident
and good communicators.
This dude has all the secrets. If you
ever present your project at a conference,
you're going to need these
skills and as always,
remember to download a chrome extension
to watch these videos at two x or three
x speed.
You will save so much time that you can
instead dedicate to other things like
spending it on hacker news,
a very technical social network run
by the popular startup accelerator y
Combinator. I find that it's
a great learning resource,
but more so than the links being shared.
The comments never failed to educate
me thanks to the voting system.
The best,
most thoughtful comments percolate
up to the top and make no mistake.
The developers here are
viciously skeptical of claims
that are not thoroughly
backed by evidence,
so rest assured the top comment on any
link here is likely high quality hacker
news has a very sophisticated
algorithm to prevent a boat spamming.
So don't just share your content link
with your friend and directly to up vote.
If it is quality,
it will rise itself.
I found linkedin to be a great tool to
find quality business relationships.
I've made a fair number of deals through
the direct messaging system and sharing
my content on linkedin has proven
to get it out in front of some very
influential people.
Hashtags seemed to make a
big difference on Linkedin,
so be sure to add those to your posts
when you can just don't overdo it like
this guy.
I will say though that I don't find the
Linkedin newsfeed to be particularly
interesting, especially since
there is an ad every few posts,
but linkedin ranks very
highly on Google search,
so make sure to sell yourself
well here in your profile.
It may be the first thing people see
about you when they search your brand on
Google. Quora is another social
network for professionals.
You can learn a lot from Quora,
especially if you find similar questions
and cross check the top answers for
similarity that what you can find the
answer you're looking for and minimize the
bias of the poster.
Quora is also great for promotion.
If you're answering questions left and
right on Quora and your answers are high
quality, people will start
reaching out to you. Anecdotally,
I met a guy at a recent conference in
New York City who was invited to speak
just because of the quality
of his Quora answers.
The same goes for stack
overflow developers get
poached all the time from this
social network for top answers.
It shows just how much you know about a
particular topic and perhaps the fastest
way to feel a part of a community is
to use chat platforms like slack or get
her.
Since the communication is so instant.
Slack chat rooms by
default are invite only,
but you can easily set up a web app
that you can send to other people to
automatically give them
access to your slack.
Community hours is now
approaching 20,000 developers,
which is pretty insane and you can find
an awesome list of slack communities for
all sorts of technical subcategories
on slow file.com lastly,
get hub is indeed a social network
and it's best as a learning resource.
If you have a question about some
concept or theory and computer science,
chances are someone has some working well
documented readable example code that
will give you a better
idea of how it works.
The key is to be able to search for it.
It's the right way.
You are ideally looking for code and it's
100 lines or less like this repo that
demos a blockchain and just a few lines
of python searching for keywords like
lines or example and your topic.
We'll get you some good results and
don't shy away from languages you don't
usually code in except for PHP.
It's well documented.
It doesn't matter.
Get as good at searching,
get up as you are on Google and you'll
have unlocked on incredible learning
resource. Interact with developers on
any given project by opening up an issue.
If you see some parts of the code that
needs work and they'll let you know if
that's the case,
the more pull requests you get
merged into a given repository,
the more you become a part
of that open source project.
A lot of times you have to prove yourself
worthy to these core contributors.
These social networks offer
developers everywhere.
A massive opportunity to learn,
engage,
and promote your product
or brand to developers.
Developers are becoming
the new influencers.
So we should all get our
social media game on point.
Just like the Instagram stars
posting selfies of themselves,
drinking smoothies to spread your brand
across multiple social media platforms
and linkedin altogether by posting links
on one social media platform to all the
other ones ready to take over the world
yet cause I am please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now
I'm going to generate some hype.
So thanks for watching.